hello everybody my name is jacob collier
and i'm a musician
today i'll be playing and transforming a
familiar tune
through a variety of different emotions
of increasingly abstract natures the
song
londonderry air otherwise known as danny
boy
i'll be playing this tune a few times
and as i'm doing so
emotions of increasing complexity will
be fired at me in real time
the challenge will be to seamlessly
transition from one emotion to the next
without stopping playing the tune
i have not been showing these emotions
in advance so what you'll be seeing is a
real-time intuitive musical process
as i try to explain or describe these
emotions one after the other
after each performance i'll be doing a
boatload of musical analysis
describing what's going on in my brain
as i'm making these musical decisions
i have never attempted anything like
this before in my entire life i'm quite
excited
a little bit nervous i think it's gonna
be really challenging and it's gonna be
really fun
let's give it a shot okay so three
different tiers of emotional complexity
to work with ranging from tier one the
most simplistic for the emotions to tier
more abstract compound emotions to tier
3 the least defined
most subjective states of all let's
begin with tier 1.
here goes
[Music]
so that was my attempt at describing six
tier one emotions happy sad angry
mysterious triumphant and serene let's
take this apart
so with happy we begin in the key of f
major and one thing you may notice
is that i'm using lots of triads here
and when i say i tried i mean like a
three note chord
which is very self-assured overall it
feels joyous
it feels bright it feels hopeful it
feels like something that resembles
happiness so generally speaking it's
pretty safe to assume that with major
chords
things tend to feel more consonant more
positive a little more comfortable
one might say happy whereas with minor
chords things often feel
less consonant a little colder sadder
more austere
especially when these chords are played
quietly
now there is something rather solemn
about these sounds we're visiting
a bit more of a transparent feeling
we're also slightly quieter
and we've ascended into the upper notes
of the piano
i'm also experimenting here with a
little dissonance see this chord
i've got this little tension here
between the g and the a flat
and interestingly this tension here is
almost like an inversion of this
tension this is attention close together
this is attention far away
both describing suppose a different kind
of sadness but there's something quite
tender i suppose about this repeated
pattern
very sad into anger
as you can see i'm playing very loudly
i'm also playing very low on the piano
now and into this dark and
dangerous zone and a lot of the notes
are also dissonant so they're not
particularly
within triads like they were with happy
or sad they are
a lore unto themselves one of the
challenges for me is how do i get
from angry too mysterious and so to
climb out of it i chose a scale
which many of you guys will be familiar
with just from watching films or seeing
theater shows it's a sound called the
whole tone scale there is an equivalent
distance between every note in the scale
and it's a scale sort of baron of
tonality and creates this extremely
interesting sense of transparent wonder
mystique
kind of strangeness a little bit of the
bizarre for me mysteriousness is all
about being
suspended almost like i'm i'm viewing
the world from above things don't make
any sense things are very confusing
but once i descend into being triumphant
the triads return these big open sounds
i'm repeating each sound three times at
the beginning
it feels almost like a national anthem
or something repeated notes
repeated chords chords that bring you
back home to f major
but when we get to f major we're very
serene
so once the triumphantness has laid out
the foundation for our return to home
what's left is the serene and as you can
see with this with this serenity there's
notes which are quieter there's fewer
notes things are feeling delicate
it's just serene okay so now it's time
for tier two
these emotions will be slightly less
defined slightly more abstract
and increasingly subjective let's give
them a shot
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
i really enjoyed that tier that was good
fun it was really challenging it was way
more challenging than tier one
they're far more abstract and they're
far less objective and i found myself
drawing far more
on my musical intuition than on my
musical knowledge
let's see what we can make of it
[Music]
so frightened lots of strange intervals
lots of odd sounds a lot of distance
between the lowest note and the highest
note
chords which create dissonance between
themselves and the melody
the feeling of general unsettlement
things feel like they're
going slightly wrong the melody which
feels so familiar is being disrupted and
re-contextualized in a very strange way
this transition from frightened
to flirtatious that's a that's a
difficult one i can't think of a single
time in my life or maybe one
or two where i've been really frightened
and then straight away i've started to
flirt with someone it's like quite rare
it's quite a quite an interesting thing
to describe musically
so you can hear me sort of being overtly
decorative here i'm playing with parts
of the melee i'm making it fun i'm
stretching out the time
and over the course of the second half
of this i'm i actually fall into a
pocket
which i suppose gives gives away to
dance
a sort of levity i suppose which one
needs when one flirts
i can tell you
so this musical confusion has some
things in common with the earlier
frightenedness
i'm taking small fragments of the melody
i'm scattering them all over the place
all around the piano high and low but
the difference here is that with
confusion
things are feeling slightly more
staccato and short and almost like
they're
creeping around i'm sort of juggling all
these different tonalities at once
it's like a sort of emotional tug of war
i can hear my ear being led in one
direction and then
me pulling that melody back and then
another direction in the other hand and
pulling that melody back reeling things
out and reading things in it's a very
confusing space
having finally made it out of the
confusion back to our starting
happy key of f major
my left hand seems to be dropping all
sorts of strange dissonant bombs
[Music]
and so after being shell-shocked at that
huge blast
it takes me a few seconds to recalibrate
and find my feet again but when i do
i'm in f sharp major
so it's almost like uh the right hand is
saying like oh wait where where where
are you
where was i where was i where was it let
me let me get started all over again
only to be disrupted yet again by
another left hand blast the left hand is
determined to get in the way of the
right hand
and finally peace in b flat major i've
also returned to a consonant
major tonality which is reminiscent of
happiness i suppose
but there's something very calm about
this and it's very flowing i've also
reintroduced
time
and there's a basic structure about that
i suppose feels comforting it feels like
there's something within it that you can
see
form in and you can lock into perhaps
you can hide in or something
and see how i'm repeating the chords
within the key center it feels sort of
cyclical almost like you're being
hugged with this warm blanket or
something it's lovely
the feeling of betrayal is such a
delicate and subtle thing to
describe because too much consonance
feels wrong but too much dissonance
feels wrong it's a very careful balance
between
absence and silence and space and
hollowness and things which are still
there but feel like they don't belong
and
there's this tension pulling between the
right hand and the left hand throughout
this section which i think
perhaps shows that feeling it it reminds
me of things in my own life where
things haven't been able to agree and
and they end up apart and it feels
awfully weird and so with the left hand
and the right hand having been unable to
agree on something the left hand just
drops out and leaves the right hand
hanging here at the end which i suppose
is as accurate a depiction of betrayal
as i
could have hoped to um to show
okay so it's time for our final tier of
emotions these are the most abstract
emotions of all
extremely subjective little defined
subtle combinations of simple estates
really open to interpretation i don't
know exactly what to expect
but we'll see where we end up on the
other side here goes
[Music]
so
the challenge of accurately describing
these spaces
comes far less from the cerebral part of
my brain and far more from the
spontaneous one
in describing these six emotions i'm
drawing on an
utterly different set of devices
experience
feelings and knowledge from both of the
previous two tiers
these are such abstract open fragile
delicate concepts to describe there's
space for me to bring my own
interpretation to
these things which is a bit of a relief
that said it was a huge challenge
let's take a listen
so seeing a long lost friend you begin
to feel comfortable within it
ah there's the long lost friend that d
major low down
feels like i've established a connection
with something
i'm noticing elements of reassuring
and serene
[Music]
the diatonic major tonality cluster
chord
the karman dynamics the amount of space
there is around the notes
here two moments of pause with a slight
change in
hue this second chord is slightly darker
from the first you see i've introduced
that b
flat in the left hand that removes your
ear from the tonality of d major
something has changed something is
altered something is being viewed from a
different light and here
i'm pivoting from the long lost friend
to inevitability
and i'm using the c sharp to get there
the c sharp belongs in the key of
a major which is where we've been but it
also belongs in the key of f sharp major
which is where we're going
and so this c sharp is a bridge from one
emotion to the next
[Music]
here comes the guilt
there's a sickening sort of weight to
these chords
like an increasing amount of heaviness
in these voicings there's a lingering
tension that you can't quite put your
finger on and each chord
presents a different relationship with
this top note and they're all
slightly uncomfortable and they all feel
heavy laden
and they all feel like they're trying to
shift the weight from one place to
another to another
they don't feel quite right it's a very
interesting musical predicament to have
found myself in
[Music]
and even though see i add that e and it
changes the whole compass of the thing
it
creates this study kind of blockade in
the middle where
something is stuck and it's forcing the
the chord to change but the e is
fighting the d
sharp in the bass and then this is f
sharp at the top there's a kind of
parallel camaraderie but there's this
lack of loyalty
which is very interesting each of these
heavy
guilty chords is repeated it's like it's
embedding itself within the music
somehow
the weight shifts from the d sharp this
closed chord to an e
a more open chord you've got e b and f
sharp is like a fifth structure
things are opening up and feeling more
transparent and here a d major triad
just to cleanse the palette
and this here is from the end of the
tune danny buoy and it's almost like a
reminiscing of something something
coming back to it feels familiar but it
also feels like it's been slightly
forgotten
and by the time we reach this f major
some piece has been found it feels like
i'm
i'm finding my way to a resting point
and f major is the resting point
followed by the c major
[Music]
and back to f the most peaceful of all
keys and this one note emerges
and with it and the repetition of it i'm
countering up all these
different musical ideas and forces to
express this jacob collier which is
about to happen
[Music]
and in true jacobian style this first
chord of the jacob collier passage is a
super
ultra hyper lydian chord it's a chord
stacked
on top of a chord stacked on top of a
chord stacked on top of a chord
at last i'm liberated from these
emotions and i'm just expressing
something
it's loud it's clear all sorts of
bundles of notes flying around all over
the place
i guess i'm used to at this point and
here's this joyous flurry in the upwards
direction
[Music]
to continue the melee at the top which
resolves in this weird surprising way
the a which you thought was going to be
part of f major is part of f
minor can you believe it
and i suppose this poses the question
well what is a perfect ending
i think for me the ending for this
particular improvisation
draws upon some of the forgiveness and
some of the happiness and some of the
reassurance and the serenity of earlier
on and the notes are becoming quieter
the range is decreasing i've entered
back into this major tonality
you can hear these nice diatonic cluster
chords things are settling down
it's time to make some kind of musical
piece it's nothing more perfect than
that
these disconnected emotions one after
the other kind of put me on the spot and
it revealed
what my immediate musical palette was
saying about me and that was
really interesting and strange and weird
and cool one of the greatest challenges
and privileges of being a musician is
the process of learning how to alchemize
the forces in your life
to create with you learn to transform
them into something which has form
structure something which can be heard
and understood even believed even by
people who don't experience the emotions
that you're drawing from
in the same way as you in some ways an
exercise like this is very far removed
from the real world composers
don't sit around trying to portray exact
emotions on a list
it's not really what happens but i do
think that it's an interesting exercise
and it definitely gets you to think
about
what you make music using like what
materials are and what parts of your
brain you're using to engage
different elements of your language a
lot of the time the most interesting
music that i write comes from emotions
that i don't really understand
and i think the process of trying to get
inside them not necessarily to control
them
or to explain them but just to get
inside them
it's the most powerful thing i can do to
be creative
by being thoughtful and nuanced around
the choices that you make
you can add so much dimension to the
music that you play
and also the music that you listen to
[Music]
you